it's great to Welcome to the program
today Scott Galloway who's professor of
marketing at nyu's Stern School of
Business and also author of adrift
America in 100 charts uh Scott great to
have you on I really appreciate it
thanks for having me David you know
there's always a risk to introducing
anyone because my audience will say well
David you're really very wrong about how
you framed this guess but one of the
things that well I'm going to
acknowledge that risk and say one of the
things I find interesting about some of
your work is you talk about uh men and
gender and masculinity in a way that to
me seems quite both empathetic but also
realistic when it comes to
men and boys without falling into what
some might describe as a sort of like a
men's rights activist type umbrella and
dismiss what you say I've actually been
really interested about a lot of the
things that you've talked about about
modern masculinity do you find that
there is a desire from those who listen
to your commentary on gender and Men
there's a desire to put you either on
this side or that side or that there
really is a sort of welcoming of the the
way you want to discuss it which I think
is much more nuanced than many others
all right thanks for the question it's a
thoughtful question I it's changed a lot
if you talked about if you advocated for
young men
two years ago and said that you know
when it was 60 40
male female in college and now it's
reversed but we're not talking about it
people saw it as a zero-sum game and
they immediately conflated advocating
for young men or highlighting some of
the struggles young men face as being
misogynist
you couldn't be Pro male without being
anti-female
and over the last 24 months has changed
and unfortunately I think some of that
is because a lot of the
a lot of the kind of pro there was a lot
of thinly veiled misogyny masking is pro
mail I don't I think some of the
celebrities that are or people on Tick
Tock that have gotten some attention it
just blatantly a fairly conservative
um there's some there's some troubling
aspects to to some of the people who've
been labeled as Pro mail and that is
they're blaming women or that some of
their content does come off as
misogynist so I don't think that's
helped have a serious conversation but
you have people like Richard Reeves and
talking his great book of Boys to Men
I've read about half of it so far yeah I
have said look this is clearly an issue
and the the group I hear from I hear
from three cohorts I hear from young men
and oftentimes they're upset because I
think I'm accusing them of being in
cells and so I get both positive and
negative feedback from young men I get
some negative feedback from young women
who feel as if look where where were you
men have had a 400 year Head Start where
were you when women were struggling and
I would argue well I think we were there
for women and we still have work to do
but I think Society has been there
um the people I get the most support
from hands down are mothers and the
conversation goes something like this I
have two daughters one's a pen one's in
PR in Chicago both killing it and I have
a son who's in the basement vaping and
playing video games and the data is just
overwhelming and we're finally having an
honest conversation about the fact that
three times as likely to be addicted
four times as likely to kill themselves
12 times as likely to be incarcerated uh
two for every one male college graduate
in the next year uh five years we're
gonna have two female college graduates
so there are real issues here and also
there's an emerging class or recognition
that the people who would like more
economically and emotionally viable
young men is women
so I I think we're finally having what
I'd call a civil conversation around it
one of the things that I find really
interesting and I hope I'm summarizing
some of the things you've written and
said accurately and if not I'm sure
you'll tell me is that you point out or
I at least interpret some of the things
you say is pointing out that some of the
Grievances that maybe the more
right-leaning folks on this issue have
about the state of young men
are a direct result of some of the
cultural shifts and norms and stories
that are told by those very people in
terms of I'll give a few examples
um what is what is masculine when it
comes to Parenting as an example and
these images of and stereotypes of hey
you know the the dad pushing around the
stroller rather than working that's not
masculine in the way that it should be
for as an example or that's my example
not yours necessarily or stories about
you know empathy and being in touch with
one's emotions should be uh should not
be welcomed for example among so-called
masculine men it seems to mean I'm
curious whether you agree that some of
those stories may be perpetuate the very
problems that you're pointing out
yeah it's an interesting conversation
because I think masculinity is a
wonderful thing and it's been
incorrectly conflated with toxicity
which is just [ __ ] toxic masculinity
is a term that has really been
destructive because there are just
certain situations where people want to
demonstrate masculinity and the key is
to Define what it means I think it means
being more risk aggressive it means
Taking Chances
if I tried to distill a modern or a
mature form of masculinity down to a
statement it would be acquiring skills
and strengths such that you can protect
and advocate for others and by the way
masculinity is not the sole domain of
people born as men I think a lot of
women demonstrate masculinity I think a
lot of men demonstrate wonderful
feminine attributes I'm kind of most of
my friends I would describe as as having
more feminine attributes than the
majority of men but let's celebrate
femininity in the wonderful things it
brings to the fore and also masculinity
so I believe for example and I've gotten
for saying this I think every man should
take economic responsibility for their
household and by the way sometimes that
means recognizing as much as it may hurt
that your partner is better at that
whole money thing than you and taking
more responsibility for supporting her
career his career and getting out of the
way I think that's a masculine attribute
somebody and ideally both of you need to
take economic responsibility for the
household I think being really really
strong
in having incredible grit and resilience
lifting heavyweights running long
distances in your mind and in the gym is
a wonderful thing men are stronger than
women lean into that they're stronger
physically women are stronger in terms
of their ability to endure you know they
have much higher threshold for pain
otherwise they would never survive
childbirth yeah but I say to young men
if you are not strong you should be able
to walk in any room and have the
confidence that if she's not real you
could kill and eat everybody or outrun
them and I'm not suggesting you do
either of those things but I'm
suggesting it's a wonderful thing to
lean into and there's nothing wrong with
it and then what you do with that
strength you're more confident you're
more kind in certain situations you
de-escalate the situation the strongest
most impressive men I've ever met in a
bar fight are the ones that step in and
de-escalate the situation that's what it
means to be a man that's what it means
to do to express masculinity so I like
the idea of trying to Define you know if
you're Tarzan what Vines you're going to
swing on masculinity for me when I was
you know you look like a very young man
David but when I was young I thought
masculinity meant being awesome sleeping
with as many strange women as possible
and being ripped I didn't go into the
gym to get fit I went in to be big and
now as I've gotten older I find that you
know being Civic voting being friendly
to your neighbors taking an interest in
a child that isn't yours I think that
being really strong you know now for my
age and I hate to say that I have to
qualify everything for my age those
things make me feel strong like ball and
I'm leaning into those things I love
those things I love making and spending
a lot of money I love protecting people
and I'm doing a lot of virtue signaling
right now but those are masculine
attributes I'm I'm a risk aggressive
person I've started businesses and
there's nothing and I'm physical on a
lot of dimensions and those are
wonderful attributes and by the way
women can demonstrate those attributes
but masculinity should be absolutely
celebrated when ukrainians or when
Russians pour over the Border
as Bill Maher said you know the
Ukrainian Army you want some of that big
energy and I don't think there's
anything wrong with that I think we need
to celebrate it it comes with downsides
it comes with upsides as does every
other attribute of the species
but um I I'd say lean into it and just
Define what it means and we need a more
mature
um version of masculinity last thing I
want to mention on this and then I want
to talk about the book a little bit I'm
curious I I've not heard you comment on
this and I don't know if you have one of
the things I've observed over the last
six to 18 months in the political space
has been that one of the topics that
gets the biggest rise out of right-wing
crowds and by this I'm talking about
your typical Trump rally as well as CPAC
in Texas over the summer what got the
crowd the most excited was stuff about
gender and trans people the one of the
biggest Applause lines at CPAC over the
summer was when Ted Cruz said my
pronouns are kiss my ass and the crowd
went absolutely crazy one of the biggest
Applause lines during the Trump rally is
when Trump talks about
a trans woman in a weightlifting
competition easily lifting hundreds of
pounds more than everybody else and just
how you know we got we got to get men
out of women's sports Etc
Etc do you make anything or what do you
make of the fact that those stories have
become so titillating to a large portion
of the country
well when when everything isn't you know
when everything is a nail you know all
you have or is what looks like a
cultural war and that is we don't want
to talk about income inequality we don't
want to talk about inflation or growing
the economy so let's get people
emotionally triggered by a small number
of
uh instances the the governor of South
Dakota spends precious resources and
time trying to pass a law that protects
women's sports from transgender athletes
and by the way conceptually it's a
conversation worth having I don't think
a six foot five person born as a male
who's had testosterone pour over their
muscle and bone structure should be
competing in what had traditionally been
a woman's swimming I think that's an
honest conversation we should have but
when you have the governor of a state
passing laws the quote unquote protect
girls Sports and then we find there
isn't a single instance in the entire
state
of a of a person who has tried to be
compete as a woman who was born a male
you have to say well are are they are
they interested in an honest
conversation or are they just interested
in triggering people and and leading a
astounded path
of demonstrating hate towards a
community that has been subjected to so
much [ __ ] it's just I mean at the
end of the day the far right claims to
embrace Jesus we're supposed to be
loving people we're supposed to be
accepting of them we're supposed to be
and they also one of the things I love
about GOP principles is in really tough
issues you defer to the individual why
wouldn't we let families and doctors
figure out what is or isn't the right
thing about this if we end up in a
Statewide swim meet okay let's have a
conversation but we're talking about
it's again it's it's a similar
conversation where they say well
Democrats want you to be able to abort
your baby you know the week before you
your water breaks that doesn't happen
it's a theoretical situation meant to
trigger people emotionally and divide us
it's not productive it's rooted in hate
it's rooted in cheap politics and it it
it doesn't Advance us forward one of the
things from my book is a segue to the
book looking at all the issues of plague
us David whether it's income inequality
whether it's the very serious issues
around climate change whether it's you
know our polarization if America's
problems are a horror movie it would be
the call is coming from inside of the
house
instead of taking time to focus on how
we
establish more chips to ensure that
we're not relying on the Chinese during
a conflict instead of focusing on how we
ensure that we bring up our bottom fifth
of education level that we get one out
of five households out of poverty that
have children we start talking about
this [ __ ] and we start talking and
when I say [ __ ] I mean anything that
divides US 34 percent of Democrats I'm
sorry 54 percent of Democrats are
worried the kid's going to marry a
republican a third of people in each
party being people in the other party
are their mortal enemy Americans will
never have greater allies than other
Americans and I find the far right
especially but also the far left are
more interested in embarrassing the
other side than they are about advancing
the nation and we have to get back to a
point where we recognize first and
foremost we're Americans we're not
Republicans Democrats I'm a huge World
War II history buff I have this great
photo of these men wait into the water
as the front gate slammed down on their
landing craft heading towards Omaha
Beach in the invasion of Normandy two
out of three of these men average age 26
wouldn't leave the beach alive and I
imagine that they can suspend the time
space continuum see our problems
and go you can't fix that I can't
imagine any of those men looked at each
other and even knew who was a Republican
or a Democrat so we are energy
independent we are food independent we
have eradicated diseases we are more we
are more prosperous than any nation in
the world but we've decided we don't
like each other and when you take very
tiny examples of Trans athletes that are
meant to evoke an emotional response all
you are doing is saying I want Americans
to hate each other I don't want America
to move forward I want Americans to hate
each other we should have an honest
conversation parents who want to have an
honest conversation around gender
affirmation and be informed when a kid
under the age of 18
asks for hormone therapy at a school
that's an honest conversation we should
have that conversation but according to
Republican principles we should have it
at the school and the family level and
there are to be blunt this is really an
edge of edge case and they want to turn
it into a cultural issue because they
don't want to really talk about what
ails us so it's like come on let's get
back to where we were as Americans have
more respect for the individual and stop
using edge cases to trigger people such
that we're angry at each other it's
totally unproductive let's talk a little
bit about uh the the book again the book
is adrift America and 100 charts one of
the things that will often happen when
you talk to folks who are maybe to some
degree siled in a particular area is
there's this sometimes instinct to say
here's really the chart or the statistic
or the issue that explains all or the
vast majority of what's going on there's
this desire to be like this is the thing
really that that this is all about
and sometimes it's income inequality or
it's the climate or it's the gender pay
Gap or whatever the case may be one of
the interesting things about your book
is that you actually look at a ton of
different dimensions but I guess the
question I have is is there some
overarching
thing that you believe links these
together in terms of explaining this
adrift status quo that you point out
some some general takeaway which then we
can use to look at some of the specifics
so if you had to zero in on one Shard
that would be Ground Zero
um for the for the detonation and all
our other problems are kind of the blast
zone as you go to different outer Rings
yes it's in the early 70s up until the
early 70s productivity and wage growth
were like two snakes intertwined the
nation got more productive through
manufacturing or processes or service
Technologies and wages went up we got
much more productive wages went up a lot
we shared in our prosperity
in the early 70s wages went flat for 50
years despite the fact the productivity
kept going up and to the right and the
Delta between these two lines is
literally tens of trillions of dollars
in Surplus value that wage earners
current income
didn't get to participate in and I think
that when when you have now for the
first time in the nation's history a 30
year old man or woman isn't doing as
well as his or her parents were at the
age of 30. when you have for the first
time more than half of people under the
age of 30 are not living over the
Romantic partner or a friend they're
living with their parents you have rage
you have shame you have roommates
reminding you of your failure every day
named mom and dad and when people aren't
doing well when the ultimate compact in
our society and that is your kids will
do better than you has been broken
people look for scapegoats they get
angry they start be leaving in uh
conspiracy theory they start looking for
Heroes and cult figures that will rally
them and blame somebody else and tell
them that they're victims so the lack of
shared progress we've been enormously
prosperous over the last 50 years we
will produce this month we will we will
produce more output this month and we
produce an entire year in the 1950s it's
our you could see in five to ten years
we might be able to produce as much in a
quarter order is we produce in a decade
in the middle of the last century the
problem is a lot of that Prosperity is
not translating to progress because if
you don't feed the engine that fights
your Wars pays the majority of your
taxes and is responsible for civility
and progress in our nation see above the
middle class a society declines China
has brought 500 million people into the
middle class in the last 50 years we've
shed 10 million so in some ground zero
the epicenter is when wages decoupled
from productivity and does that I mean I
can speculate about how that would
connect to
education that would connect to dealing
with climate issues that would connect
to Social Services access to health care
I mean it seems as though when you think
about that particular chart where you
start to see a separation between
productivity and wage growth you really
can connect that to so many of the
different charts and things you talk
about
yeah it really it just ripples out and
what you have is
um there's this there's a few myths that
we need to bust the first is that the
middle class is a naturally occurring
economic Force it's not if you let the
economy just run totally you know Iron
Rand is totally free market the middle
class starts to erode because wealthy
people get access to powerful
politicians especially with citizens
united who tend to take the tax code
from 400 pages to 4 000 who can navigate
a complex tax code the wealthy if you
can navigate By Starlight you want to
you want to run boat races at night
where run our tax code is complex people
at my income level can afford people to
help them navigate and we end up with a
regressive tax structure education me
and my colleagues every morning wake up
in the morning and say ask ourselves one
question how do we reduce our
accountability while increasing our
compensation we have found the ultimate
strategy and that is to tap into the 10
wealthiest American households with a
luxury positioning and that is
artificially constrained Supply such
that 30 20 10 admission rates and we
stand up and applaud the dean and the
alumni love it and we've morphed towards
this [ __ ] rejectionist luxury
positioning in our society where once I
have a degree from a good University I
want them to pull up the drawbridge
because then my degree becomes more
valuable once I have a house I show up
to the local review board and try and
squash any new development to make my
the price of my house go up and once I
have a successful tech company I
weaponize the government to not let any
emerging companies come out of the crib
through Monopoly abuse if we don't
consistently create opportunities for
other people to enjoy the prosperity of
my generation as enjoined if you don't
have TR if you don't have churn if you
don't stop these ridiculous bailouts of
small businesses and create a cartoon
the wealthiest people in America are
small business people when you just
bail out rich people and companies
you're robbing from young people because
the reason I'm wealthy is because as I
was coming into my Prime income
millionaires in 2008 Amazon and apple
went down 90 and I got to buy them and
then register a 20 and 40-fold
respectively increase and two years ago
we decided to bail out the markets and
as a result as a result young people
didn't get their shot to buy Brooklyn
real estate or Amazon stock you know at
forty sixty seventy percent off so
America used to be the best place to get
rich it slowly but surely become the
best place to stay Rich everything we do
right now fiscally and legislatively is
an attempt to take money from a younger
generation who have seen their wealth
from go from 19 of GDP to nine percent
we have cut the wealth of people your
age in half the average person
seven-year-old is 72 percent wealthier
than they were 40 years ago the person
average person under the age of 40 is 22
percent less wealthy My Generation has
basically said to a younger generation
[ __ ] you I got mine get yours I'm going
to borrow your credit card and your kids
credit card such that Nana and pop-op
can upgrade from Carnival to Crystal
Cruises unless we reinvest in the middle
class it will correct and the means of
Correction will either be War famine or
revolution
uh I I hate to end on such a Negative
salad wasn't it not every not every
interview has a happy ending which is
okay which is okay uh we've been
speaking with Scott Galloway professor
of marketing at NYU also author of
adrift America in 100 charts Scott I
really appreciate your time and talking
to me today
David thanks for your good work and
thanks for having me